[Music]
just steps from her back door the flames
almost reached victoria's home her
garden now blackened and burnt out and
she knows she was lucky to escape
the whole sky over there was black
and i could see like an actual red flame
you see it coming close and i just
thought
you know i don't know if my house is
going to be here when i come back
the fire at felsome in west london
spread along the backs of these homes
fueled by dry undergrowth and scorching
temperatures
it's kind of material things i need to
say so it's
all replaceable there was little
neighbours dave and graham could do
i grabbed my hose
and i tried to put it out with my hose
but it wasn't making any difference at
all everything spread so quickly you
know and everything said dry and the
trees especially the trees over there
the big trees at the back here they went
up like an
explosion
the fire so fierce nothing survived this
was my shed at one time it contained
many years of
memorabilia
uh i had a lawn mower hedge trimmers
garden streamers old me football
programs yeah a bit upset about those
very much yes uh 60 years of collecting
their football programs mainly chelsea
is that an old one there that's an old
it's an old qpr whatever you know
the fire spread really quickly through
these gardens literally destroying
everything in its path and it came so
close to the houses as well if you look
here you can see how it's melted away
the roof up there
wildfires have burned across parts of
england this one near truro in cornwall
sending smoke over the land
near stonehenge a midsummer spectacle no
one wanted to witness and here in
chelmsford a cul-de-sac evacuated as
fire spread close to houses
we're planning for the worst and hoping
for the best so we're all our planning
is in place so what we are you know
we're thinking we may see more of this
week are field fires grass fires so what
we're asking the public to do is just
take more care when they're out and
about
in the week beginning the 18th of july
the london fire brigade received over 8
000 calls
with firefighters attending a thousand
fires
this map from the met office shows how
severe fires would be if they started by
friday the red spots mark areas where
the severity is exceptional meaning
fires would spread quickly and be
difficult to contain
become saturday it'll be worse
a heat health alert starts at midday on
tuesday and as the hot dry weather
continues there's real worry what this
week will bring laura bundock sky news